Somewhere in
this forlorn
corner of a not so forgotten bat
six Ukrainian soldiers are missi
believed dead Leonid Bonder and
man military recovery
team have come to look for them.
The highlight was a live report,
and it's important for their fam
for us,
for the country
that we bring them home for them
And now they are the first to se
Since Ukraine retook this area,
from Russian troops
six weeks ago will retired.
Dangers abound.
Mine's a deadly menace, he expla
Russians shelled
and overran the position late sp
What happened in the soldier's
final moments
and to their mortal remains
is the mystery.
Bonder and his team
have come to solve the
lives ended in an instant.
Now, perhaps the story's not ove
We'll pursue all of you honest.
We worked out the possibility
of the bodies flying after the e
and thus found the remains of
two more fighters. Go
by the end of the first day.
Bond is finding clues.
And something else, too.
Something he feared.
Russian inhumanity.
There's bits of metal from ammun
cases here. And bone fragments.
A piece, perhaps from a leg
piece of skull over here.
The investigators think that per
the Russians try to burn the bod
over the water.
The following day, the team back
digging in the bunker
where they think the soldiers
hid during the shelling.
Meanwhile, Bonder
collects the bones of a soldier
thrown from the blast.
Every fragment recovered a possi
DNA lead
and potential solace for loved o
And then he discovers a ring.
There's also a mystery Shaka
helpful for identification, he s
But the bones also confirmation
of what he feared.
Russians callously burned
this fallen soldiers body
was in the process of
glee.
This is not the first
time we have encountered
a situation
where the norms of humanity
are neglected.
And soldiers are not properly bu
WADA made the torture people
back in the bunker
important finds bone fragments.
Their hunch.
The soldiers huddled here
getting traction
Then the unexpected.
Other Ukrainian soldiers take th
to a dead Russian soldier
they just discovered nearby.
His remains recorded, recovered,
given the same respect
as their own fallen
in the bunker.
More progress.
Several bodies located
beneath the rubble.
Come on home, brother Leonid whi
as the fallen
soldiers broken body gently is f
Then the next soldier gun in han
pried out.
His documents, located what time
we currently provide, is structu
Thank you for helping us identif
you, Bond tells the body
the abortion would be at your di
We've seen five of our fellow se
Questions remain about one more
when we raise these.
We will see if he is there to
those found
soon to
be reunited with their grieving
Their final moments better under
bond and his team vow
to keep searching for the sake
they know.
They may not be able to find out
all the details
of how these soldiers died.
The only certainty here is
that as long as the war goes on,
their job is far from over.
Now, we've been in touch with Bu
and his team again.
They are still searching for tha
missing member.
They think he might just have be
a long way from the bunker,
but they're also under pressure
now to expand their searches
to other areas.
President Zelensky said at times
the death toll has been 50
Ukrainian soldiers a day.
There's hundreds of square miles
that these
that the recovery team
have left to cover.
Many more soldiers
many more fallen heroes to bring